para hacer cambios positivos.
Todos podemos contribuir al cambio.
Como dije, soy diseñadora
y quisiera cambiar las cosas a través del diseño.
Les daré algunos ejemplos de mi trabajo.
Estoy colaborando con Swarovski, la empresa de cristales.
Si uno corta los cristales de cierto modo,
la luz se puede curvar y dirigir hacia un lugar específico.
Así que uso estos cristales para concentrar la luz en un panel solar,
y los hago más eficientes, pero usando la estética.
Entonces, si exponemos este cristal solar a la luz
--esa célula solar tiene una batería--
y luego la ponemos sobre la base de carga,
podemos dar energía a esas lámparas.
Así que literalmente traemos la luz al interior.
Y la energía solar me atrapó totalmente cuando descubrí esta tecnología
llamada "célula solar sensibilizada por colorante",
células solares coloreadas,
que se basan en la fotosíntesis de las plantas.
Así como la clorofila verde convierte la luz en azúcares para las plantas,
estas células convierten la luz en electricidad.
Lo mejor es que incluso funcionan en el interior.
Y colores distintos tienen una eficacia diferente
según su lugar en el espectro de colores.
Por ejemplo, el rojo es más eficiente que el azul.
Así que, si como diseñadora pienso:
"Si en una superficie de vidrio coloreada,
donde el color se usa mayormente para la estética,
pero ahora tiene una función extra, porque puede recolectar electricidad,
entonces, ¿dónde puedo aplicarlo?".
Esta es una mesa
cuya superficie está enteramente formada por estas células solares coloreadas.
En las patas tiene baterías
donde se puede recargar el teléfono a través de los puertos USB.
Y en mi trabajo siempre es muy importante
el equilibrio entre la eficiencia y la estética.
Por eso la mesa es naranja,
ya que es un color muy estable para los interiores.
Y esto es lo que siempre me preguntan más:
"Fantástico, pero ¿cuánto teléfonos puedo entonces cargar en ella?".
Y antes daba una respuesta complicada como:
"Bien, ¿dónde está la mesa?, ¿tiene suficiente luz?,
¿está cerca de una ventana?".
Pero ahora la mesa tiene sensores que leen la intensidad de la luz en la habitación.
Y a través de una app que desarrollamos
pueden ver cuánta luz está recibiendo y el estado de carga de la batería.
Estoy orgullosa, porque ayer instalamos una mesa
en las oficinas de Stichting DOEN en Ámsterdam
y, en este preciso momento,
nuestra reina Máxima está cargando un teléfono en esta mesa.
Es genial.
(Aplausos)
Así que, cuanta mayor es la superficie, más energía se pueden recolectar.
Estas son ventanas que hemos creado;
reemplazamos todas las ventanas de una galería en Soho, en Londres,
con esta versión moderna de vitrales.
De modo que la gente de la calle puede ir y cargar su teléfono
desde el borde de las ventanas.
De este modo, le doy una función extra a los objetos.
Una ventana ya no debe ser una simple ventana.
También puede funcionar como una pequeña central eléctrica.
Pero aunque estoy hablando de lo mucho que amo la energía solar,
yo no tengo paneles solares en mi techo.
Vivo en el centro de Ámsterdam,
la casa no es mía y, además, es un monumento,
así que no es posible y no está permitido.
Entonces, ¿cómo podemos hacer células solares más asequibles y para todos,
y no solo para la gente que puede permitirse un estilo de vida sostenible?
Ahora tenemos la oportunidad
de integrar la energía solar directamente donde la necesitamos.
Y hay muchas tecnologías maravillosas.
Si ahora miro alrededor, veo cada superficie como una oportunidad.
Por ejemplo, un día, mientras viajaba en tren por Westland,
una región de los Países Bajos donde están todos los invernaderos,
vi esa gran cantidad de vidrio y pensé:
"¿Y si les incorporamos vidrio solar transparente?
¿Y si unimos la agricultura tradicional, que requiere mucha energía,
con la de alta tecnología y las combinamos?".
Con esta idea en mente, creé una "planta nuclear".
Se hizo con un equipo de arquitectos e ingenieros,
pero primero les explicaré cómo funciona.
Usamos vidrio solar transparente para dar energía al clima del interior.
Usamos hidroponía, que hace circular agua con nutrientes,
lo que ahorra un 90 % en el consumo de agua.
Al ponerlos en capas, el rendimiento por metro cuadrado es mayor.
Además de la luz solar, la instalación de lámparas LED de colores
también estimula el crecimiento de las plantas.
Como cada vez más gente vivirá en las grandes ciudades,
si colocamos este sistema en las azoteas,
ya no será necesario traerlas de otras partes del mundo,
pues podremos cultivarlas en el lugar.
El sueño es construirlas en sitios sin conexión a la red eléctrica,
sin acceso al agua o la electricidad, como un ecosistema independiente.
Para la Bienal de diseño de este año
he creado el primer modelo de la planta de energÍa, de 4 metros de altura,
de modo que pueden venir y ver cómo crecen las plantas.
De esta manera, se aprovecha doblemente la luz del sol:
para las células solares y para las plantas.
Es como un jardín botánico del futuro,
en el que celebramos todas estas tecnologías modernas.
Y el mayor cumplido que recibí fue: "Pero, ¿dónde están los paneles solares?".
Ahí es cuando creo que el diseño funciona,
cuando se vuelve invisible y nadie lo nota.
Creo en la democracia solar:
energía solar para todos, en todas partes.
Mi objetivo es convertir todas las superficies en algo productivo.
Quiero construir casas en las que todas las ventanas, las cortinas, las paredes,
incluso los pisos recolecten electricidad.
Piensen en esto a gran escala.
En las ciudades hay muchas superficies.
El sol todavía está disponible para todos.
Y al integrar la energía solar donde la necesitamos
podemos lograr que las células solares sean asequibles para todos.
Quiero, junto con Uds., acercar la energía solar a la gente,
pero bella y bien diseñada.
Gracias.